spent number 16. Lady Gaga
[Music]
a strong sexual undertone how important
in your
artist really is that it's a sexuality
it's as important to me as it is to you
isn't sex important to everyone all the
way back in 2009 when Lady Gaga wasn't
yet the mega star she is now she was
asked a question about whether she's
scared that the provocative nature of
her songs would overshadow her musical
Talent having sexual references can it
undermine music because the sexual
references
um a lot of people focused on that I'm
not scared are you scared no she
responded confidently that men who write
songs about sex are called Rock Stars
while she gets asked questions about
whether it will negatively affect her
image but when I do it my music and in
my videos
because I'm a female because I make pop
music you are judgmental and you say
that it is uh
um distracting she ain't finished by
yeah because men and women are different
I'm if we're gonna go off a technicality
I guess maybe that one qualifies
but not you know what not really no no
I'm I'm back up back up if you're gonna
be doing all this sexual stuff on camera
and it's a part of your shows you can't
be mad if someone asks you about it just
like if there was a magic mic Style Show
okay
a few dudes doing like Magic Mike style
so I'm they might get asked about it too
I don't
think we're reaching like what I'm just
thinking we're talking to our grandmas
great grandmas from the 1920s and they
say what what sexism have you
experienced and she said well
I was twerking on stage and someone
asked me about it
I think they might think we're soft I
don't know saying that she's just a rock
star and there's no way anyone could
deny that especially now after more than
a decade at the top of the music
industry I'm just a rock star number 15
Simone biles While most of the other
celebrities on our list are actors or
musicians this Olympic Athlete is also
not immune to receiving sexist questions
you let out the signature Simone smile
after you did your trick which was great
but that was very authentic there was an
authenticity Simone biles appeared on a
season of Dancing With the Stars and
after one of her performances host Tom
Bergeron questioned why she wasn't
smiling when receiving compliments about
her performance I was waiting for you to
smile at some of the compliments you
didn't
come on Tom haven't we all learned by
now not to ask women to smile luckily
biles had oh wow oh no
we're looking to be a fast swear to God
I just keep I keep thinking like like
lady from the 19 1900s saying like what
sexism do you experience and I said
well I was asked why I wasn't smiling
once like maybe you look sad I don't
know
I just I just feel like we're so quick
in this culture to be offended rather
than giving someone the benefit of the
doubt maybe she looked depressed
maybe like I mean it's kind of awkward
when someone's saying great job and
you're like
and I I don't know okay a perfect
response ready saying that smiles don't
win you gold medals ain't that the truth
the last time I showed emotion it was at
the Olympics and I got a bronze instead
of gold number 14 Mark Ruffalo you know
sometimes exactly what I want to hear
isn't exactly what I want to hear
Scarlett Johansson is used to receiving
sexist questions while promoting Marvel
movies more on that later but in this
Cosmopolitan UK video the interviewer
decided to flip the script and let
Johansen take the serious questions
while Mark Ruffalo was offered the
queries typically asked to female stars
feel free to embrace your feminine side
Mark I do it every single day and you
put the premiere tonight so Mark what
are you wearing on the red carpet this
evening
uh a suit he played up just how
ridiculous these standard questions are
when asked about his Red Carpet wardrobe
the most flattering poses for
photography and his diet and exercise
regimen so did you feel much pressure to
slim down and get in shape go on a diet
mark
not really I I uh made a bunch of peanut
butter did some push-ups did some
push-ups I did my prison I have a prison
routine from here on out let's just ask
everyone the same questions no matter
their gender okay
number 13 Jennifer Aniston okay no
uterus no opinion it seems like there
have been Jennifer Aniston pregnancy
rumors on the cover of tabloids in line
at the grocery store for pretty much
decades now another wonderful photograph
which I've had to sort of live with for
the last God 10 15 years of picture of
me with a bump and a circle around my
stomach Aniston has understandably tired
of the persistent questions she receives
about her desire to be a mother and
explained in an interview with Allure
saying quote I don't like the pressure
that people put on me on women that you
failed yourself as a female because you
haven't procreated I don't think it's
fair okay it's not fair but that's
society I'm sorry it's just if you get
to a certain age as a woman and you
don't have kids people look at you kind
of funny and you can try to undo the
programming you can try to reprogram
people to think it's normal and think
it's not weird but throughout all of
human history women have reproduced the
majority of women have reproduced
the majority of men have not reproduced
throughout all of human history that's
why it's weird
anyways
um you're welcome to do what you want to
do but it's like you make your bed lie
in it you know that that happens and you
can't tell me Jennifer Aniston hasn't
had the chance to have children she's
stunning
went on to say that being maternal
doesn't simply need to be about having
biological children and that she is
mothering to her friends dogs and
Friends children yeah but
when you're 60 is that going to be
enough 70 when your looks good I mean
don't go me wrong her look she's kept up
her looks for a very long time but at
some point no one's lining up to date 70
year olds so what do you have then
myself with my amazing work my amazing
partner my beautiful dogs and I tuned
that noise out you know I mean I think
it's very sweet that people uh
want
everything for me I'm so content and so
happy where I am number two you believe
that Taylor Swift
it's like you see the sad in her eyes
maybe she is what do I know what do I
know
we do oh no Taylor Swift is like like
I'm a t-swift fan I think she makes Bops
and I really liked the younger Taylor
Swift but you could see her over the
years getting like programmed by this
propaganda and the older she gets it's
like
the more the more victim she becomes
exist in this Society where women in
entertainment are discarded in an
elephant graveyard by the time they're
35. well be oh
I made Millions throughout my 20s
because I'm young beautiful and talented
and now I might make less money after 35
like
guys the world is what it is interviewed
by Germany's DPA Taylor Swift was asked
whether her 30th birthday would prompt
her to settle down with a man she
refused to answer saying quote I really
doubt men get asked the same question
when they turn 30. Swift seems like
something of a magnet for sexism and
while on the Grammys yeah because men
don't have a biological clock
okay carpet Nancy O'Dell of
Entertainment Tonight commented on
Taylor's physique saying she'd be quote
going home with lots of men to which
Taylor replied that she'd simply be
hanging out with her friends and going
home to her cats you're gonna walk home
with more than maybe just a trophy
tonight I think lots of men I'm not
going to walk home with any men tonight
I'm gonna I'm gonna go hang out with my
friends and then I go home to the cats
no men allowed men get me in trouble I
don't meow number 11. Rihanna during a
red carpet interview with the launch of
her Rogue man fragrance that's crazy all
these women benefit off of sexism like
they benefit off of Beauty in a way men
don't men have to be talented a lot of
these women wouldn't be where they are
if they weren't beautiful they weren't
stunning and they're okay with sexism or
an opportunity I don't even want to say
sexism but like opportunity
when it benefits them but the downside
that comes with it which is as you age
there's less
and then they're mad it's like privilege
is invisible to those who have it and a
lot of women don't realize how
privileged they are and what position
that they're in especially like most of
these women are top 10 20 of beauty you
know how lucky you are as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible